what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey I have read all the
Hellboy comics as of today each one oh
my god the Wild Hunt night seeker its
darkness calls storm in the fury and I
even did my hair trying to do like David
Harbor and Hellboy just for this video
missing out we don't have time yeah I'm
excited to check this out man I did like
the first trailer and I'm hoping that
this one will give us a little bit more
that r-rated taste not it's got it as
official our rating before we go into
that people I would like to say thank
you to all you beautiful sons of [ __ ]
and pee holes who have been following us
on the starter step it's free to
download and usually post 30 second
reaction reviews for any film TV show or
trailer every once in a while we even do
a micro sketch there it's free to
download and you can post to would love
it if you did it today because I like
growing things
John why'd you do that would your hair
it looks so much more accurate than mine
yours looks great yours likes more and
you look sexy I look silly you know what
you're making me look bad in the video
let's watch this supposed to be red band
ooh so he'll man how man is red bad whoa
nah that's bed diamo whoa
as cool the origin is reading Thomas
Haden Church Wow I was very real
son made me a goddamn welcome
[Music]
since it either
yeah
Wow
Oh sizer great yes BPRD baby
BPR tight not alright payday BPRD
okay Jeff Bridges is held well how great
would that be an interesting movie right
there alright look first things first
everyone who watch this channel knows I
actually enjoyed the first trailer and I
believe I said in that too that that's
just the first something along the lines
of that we watch something that's it's
probably just the first trailer that
I've ever liked a second trailer even
with a red band we'll probably get a lot
more of the things that were teased
about there and sure enough they did it
like do I feel like the the full-blown
horror vibe that I've heard hints about
not really but the aesthetic is a lot
more there I felt I thought this yeah
look guys to know that about that is
true there was just so much better I
like the first one but this one made me
go damn this looks [ __ ] crazy this is
like really cool and looks a lot like a
comic book - yeah yeah yeah it looks
like it's going to have its own kind of
different heightened sensibility about I
mean Guillermo del Toro has such a
distinct quality and this looks like it
is going in its own direction with it
you know and yeah especially in the
colors and some of these close-up shots
or some of these more fantastical
looking images especially because you
know Guillermo del Toro fantasy is very
distinct and this looks like a totally
different kind of fantasy yeah which is
exciting and yeah to the tones it's like
yeah I don't get the full-on horror
movie vibe but this definitely had a lot
more of like the carnage especially like
the
BloodRayne they're like they're having
like sex achill in the blood rain man
yeah this definitely looked a lot more
pulpy and a lot more like wonder how
that scene goes down yes they're like oh
you won't want to do with me because I'm
red well no if I can get red for yes I
want to see like some of that weirdness
and the craziness is a big part of what
makes us look very distinct to me yeah
yeah yeah well it makes me wonder to
what they're again as we always do with
superhero movies what they're going to
take directly from the source material
and what they're going to kind of alter
because I've heard they're going to kind
of expand on I'm probably gonna butcher
her name Nimmi y-yeah since I am an
expert I know for sure it's NEMA way
NEMA way their way in a way yeah
the queen of blood yeah lady of the
light yeah well and that's that's I
think that's pretty no no I like that
they have that that detail because you
know it gives it a folklore clock cuz
the Lady of the lake is like a folklore
figure you've heard about a lot of this
is that faux Clara folklore element and
there's some common fog this is seems to
be very King Arthur as probably he's
weirdly an Excalibur setting it on fire
it's all very King Arthur inspiring I
think Hellboy with his character is a
descendant of King Arthur yeah I didn't
actually read the comics all right did I
watch a lot of things in preparation
this week to do this video of course I
did cuz I do that for you guys so I
could be a little bit more in the know
on this and I would like to read the
comic books I would let's just go off
with this as a trailer alone I just
remembered that that I thought it was
really cool that they've built this
character out of that kind of
recognizable I don't know yeah just
recontextualizes the other myths - yeah
and I like the tone of this one you know
I felt like the tone for the first
trailer kind of confused some people I
didn't believe that was the actual tone
of that movie yeah it seemed like a
first trailer whereas this like the
humor seems to work with a lot more of
its more serious elements you know well
yeah this trailer feels more like a
trailer for the movie whereas the first
trailer to me felt like a trailer for
the character hell yeah you know like
here's is
having fun he's wisecracking he's kind
of a fish out of water but he's got
these badass qualities too and this one
seemed to have just a better picture and
especially because when you get the
recontextualize origin exactly I feel
like it's gonna be like the opening
scene of the movie yeah because I know
and Del Toro's version we did that but
this is a new rendition I feel like some
people still get a little confused
whether or not if it's boy 3 it's not a
hell boy 3 guys well and you know it's
only the first time we've rebooted the
Hellboy film yes Beauty guys but yeah I
mean a lot of what David Harbor has even
talked about like in that II W interview
especially with showing a darker
grittier version of Hellboy and I feel
like there is gonna be a pretty clear
arc with this guy because there was
something where he did say he feels like
he's struggling with the idea of whether
or not
yeah Hellboy is a good guy or a bad guy
in this world and it seems like a lot of
I'm just gonna call me a Jovovich it's
like I'm here Jovovich that a lot of
that internal struggles gonna be there I
feel like with the film itself will
probably get a really personal
relationship maybe she won't have a lot
of screen time her threat level seems
really good but I imagine that with
Hellboy and her especially with that one
shot where they're like really close to
each other like how we do every night
before we go to bed yeah the blood sorry
I it's solely no budded you and our
improv and that's not how you improv yes
next time I have to do better and with a
Ben diamond I've heard some people talk
about with my friends who are much more
bigger experts on it's a lot of bad
English they're a lot more big of what's
more bigger a lot of my friends who are
bigger fans of Hellboy they talked about
Ben DiMeo um who was really supposed to
be played by ed skrein sitting on his
shoulder she would be and they would
have liked that he is like a werepanther
and some of they some of them did not
seem to know whether or not for sure he
was gonna have that ability but they've
we know they're soft
that was pretty badass looking like I'm
excited to see them go who go up against
grew of Gok yeah guys name is well all
the designs look freaking cool yeah a
lot of this looks very cool I had the
honor of flipping through a Hellboy
comic and going wow did you know like
looking at these images that couldn't
let some of these seem like new images
of what I've heard but they seemed like
they all have Mike Mignola's a approval
of it mm-hmm you know you know what I
mean
oh yeah I mean this is yes this seems to
be their opportunity to make it like the
source material with the big trailers
return out to cut these so I'm trying to
make this as complicated for us to film
as possible yeah I mean from what I
understand he's been heavily involved in
the inception of this particular movie
and and it looks like I don't know at
least what I'm getting from him and me
liova vich together like you know as
part of his deal is he's supposed to
bring about the end of you know the end
times of earth and stuff like that so
like I bet she's trying to coerce him
into being that you know putting on the
sexy well in this final shot though like
when it looks like all of London has
fallen
yeah ha ha London has fallen meets
Constantine in this shot right in the
dragon like he's gonna become full-on
Hellboy here oh yeah yeah horns and all
he's a king of England better yet Prime
Minister's co-presidents of number 10
the Beast of the Apocalypse right here
I'm loving it and that's just such a
badass image to see I'm riding that
thing and yeah I don't know I'm really
excited to get to the finale of that I
got imagine that's worth it oh yeah the
first 15 minutes first no I did the
origin of him as a baby being born with
the Nazis and everything as to the end
of his life to the end the rest of the
movie in the middle Channel that's what
I like to see honestly I feel like this
is one of the chairs that lends itself
to Sunday read you just take it frame by
frame and start theorizing or breaking
down elements of it yeah well yeah yeah
yeah and comparing it to the older
trailer - you're like okay so we've seen
a few snippy yeah this point in time we
know he gets his undead army right time
and then
yeah Zika raises I don't know daddy yeah
yeah XK Excalibur and he raises the you
know remaining r3 and Knights to fight
yeah
I look at some of these like that shot
with me a Jovovich and him or the really
close to each other does look like out
of a fantasy you know yeah yeah yeah
what and I'll say it to that this
trailer does really give itself a
distinct style and flare that's that's
the thing that I felt was ultimately
missing from the first trailer was okay
I'm yeah I'm getting certain things from
it but what is the overall distinct
style and look of this movie and it
feels like they do have some really
striking visuals here yeah yeah I'm
excited for this movie man because Neil
Marshall I mean Neil Marshalls got chops
for that kind of stuff and it's funny
you should mention Constantine earlier
cuz I believe he was heavily involved
with the show but yeah he's got and and
that's I'm excited for this because he's
got such a strong horror sensibility
from the flicks I've seen of his anyway
yeah and you know I think he's a great
choice for this dude this is gonna be
awesome I'm sure there's a lot of things
we've missed he can resurrect British
Knights see cuz I'm a comic book expert
yeah that was plenty to say about this
and I'm sure there's more and leave more
comments down below guys listen you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and download a
false and Stardust app yeah